So it's time for a good old fashioned
audience talent show.
(upbeat music)
(applause)
I am honored to announce my esteemed fellow judges.
Our first judge is known to many as the mayor of Broadway.
That's right, he's an expert in all things musical theater,
and it's Sirius XM Broadway host, Seth Rudetsky!
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Thank you.
And you know who's too legit to quit?
Ross Matthews!
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Thank you, hi everybody.
This is so exciting for us on our end,
and we can't wait to see what you guys do,
so we pluck three people from our audience
who are are about to perform on this very stage,
and let's have some fun and see what people can do.
We're gonna vote on a winner who will be coming home
with this state of the art trophy.
Gorgeous, wow.
But I mean, Seth, you performed on a stage, a screen,
you're an accomplished pianist.
Have you ever done anything like a talent show?
Why yes I have.
When I was a kid, I won most outstanding act
for playing Hyde in E minor piano Sonata.
Anybody?
Nobody.
Yeah, no, I didn't do that.
Okay, Ross, have you ever performed in a talent show?
You know, it's a shame I never did.
I did put together a whole routine in fourth grade
with Kristen Nelson, hi, girl.
We were gonna do "I had the time of my life"
From Dirty Dancing, but when my mother saw it,
she thought it was inappropriate.
I think I really committed to the dirty part
of the dirty dancing, and since I was in fourth grade,
everyone was uncomfortable.
So, I actually was a revelation,
it's a shame y'all missed out.
Little Rossy, dirty dancing, thank you.
Alright, well, let's get this party started
and say hello to our first contestant, Bernadette.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
How are you?
I'm doing good, how are you?
We're so excited to see what you are gonna do.
Will you tell us one thing about your yourself though first?
Well, I love to jump rope.
How many can you do, like, in a row?
How long can you do it?
I can do as many, probably up to 500, 600.
What?!
Wow.
So impressive.
Okay, Bernadette, show us what you've got.
Thank you for coming today.
Yes.
(upbeat music)
Oh!
Oh my God.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Are you kidding me?
Bernadette, my heart is racing,
as if I did all that jumping.
That was incredible.
I am exhausted.
Does anyone here understand how physically hard that is?
I don't understand how you just pulled that off,
and seemingly with a smile on your face,
and super effortless.
Thank you.
Well thank you, Bernadette for showing off.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Your turn, Seth.
Oh, right, I'm so sorry, here we go.
Please welcome our second contestant, Mariah.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Tell us a little bit about yourself and your talent.
Well, I'm 23 years old, I'm from Staten island, New York
and I'm a contortionist.
What?
Yes.
Wow.
(applause)
A contortionist.
You know why I love contortionists?
'Cause it's so wrong, right?
You shouldn't bend that way.
No.
But you do.
Yes.
Wow.
At home, are you totally lazy and you're like,
"I'm turning on the TV."
No, my parents are sick of it.
Will you show us what you do please, Mariah?
Okay.
Thank you.
Already I'm impressed, one knee.
(upbeat music)
Ooh, ow.
Oh, what?
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Oh my God, the back.
Wait a minute.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
What's happening?
Oh, wow.
The strength.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Are you okay?
So far.
Yeah.
And what happened to your spine, where'd it go?
Lost it long ago.
That was unbelievable.
Is there a point where you think,
"Okay, I can't do that, I can't push myself that far"
And then you do?
Yeah, yeah.
And then you what, go to the hospital?
Yeah. (laughs)
So far so good, no hospital visits yet.
Knock on all the wood in the world, Mariah.
You're amazing, thank you so much, Mariah!
(upbeat music)